this morning we have a very revealing
look at the war in Ukraine from an
American volunteer who fought in it
Ukraine's Army is preparing to try and
recapture the key southern city of her
son and fighting off Russian attacks in
the Northeast Ukraine's President says
Russian Artillery strikes are quote
driving people to their deaths Holly
Williams is in key that's Ukraine's
capital city rather with more on the
story Holly good morning to you
good morning we've been reporting on
this war now for over eight months and
it's extremely rare to get an
unvarnished account of what it's like at
the tip of the spear as Ukraine battles
Russia's Invasion but that's exactly
what we heard from an American who
volunteered to fight with Ukrainian
forces and we should warn you that his
interview contains some disturbing
material
here
shooting but then you could also hear
Grunts and people like
fighting to the death with their bare
hands
it's a very unique sound when you hear
that many death rattles
but he's from Tennessee he told us and
came to fight in Ukraine because he was
horrified by the Russian invasion he
wants to be known only by his call sign
Elvis the Carnage you're describing
sounds like something out of World War
II
yeah
this is nothing like
any conflict in the past say 70 to 80
years this war is not sustainable
for either side
on the front line in southern Ukraine he
says he repeatedly witnessed Russian
forces using white phosphorus Munitions
it comes down extremely slow but there's
nothing you can do and everything it
touches just incinerates including this
incident probably about 20 or 30 guys
burning alive
and several gunshots because there's
nothing else they do so a lot of guys
have suicide pistols and you'd hear them
scream and then
they would say goodbye and then blow
their own heads off
so you actually heard 20 to 30 soldiers
being burned alive so white Force for us
and some of them committing suicide with
their own pistols yes ma'am
oh was that must have been horrific
it's [ __ ]
at least that's what I tell myself
he admits that he's traumatized and
fears one of his former comrades could
commit suicide because of what they went
through together do you still think this
is a righteous War yes
absolutely we're fighting Pure Evil
anybody in the west that asks Ukraine to
just do peace talks they need to go
through these Villages they need to see
what's been done to these people if
China invaded the U.S
hypothetically
leveled Los Angeles leveled Seattle
Portland massacred thousands do you
think the U.S would just sue for beef
no
Russia has previously denied using white
phosphorus Munitions in Ukraine Elvis
told us that if other Americans are
thinking of volunteering with Ukraine's
military they should know that the odds
are stacked against them and they'll be
fighting for their lives Nate
other Williams that was a powerful
conversation eye-opening and also
heartbreaking thank you so much